La invasión rusa de Ucrania, el programa
nuclear iraní, la bomba norcoreana o el expansionismo
chino en el mar de la China meridional. El
mundo está que arde y la cuestión militar
vuelve a ocupar el primer plano de la política
internacional.
Porque, además, la agresión de Vladimir
Putin a Ucrania está provocando un enorme
terremoto geopolítico: ya nadie se fía de
ese vecino que no saluda casi nunca, que grita
más de la cuenta y que no resulta particularmente
amigable.
La pesadilla desatada por el Kremlin nos ha
recordado que lo inimaginable es perfectamente
posible. Así que en estos casos ser precavido
vale por dos, ¿no os parece?
Lo estamos viendo en Europa, dónde prácticamente
todos los países están anunciando inversiones
militares récords para los próximos años.
Desde el más pequeño como Estonia hasta
el más grande como Alemania.
Y también y sobre todo lo podemos ver en
Asia-Pacífico.
Porque podemos decir que últimamente las
relaciones de China con la mayor parte de
sus vecinos no pasan por su mejor momento.
China se está convirtiendo en una superpotencia
y el gobierno de Xi Jinping ha comenzando
a ser mucho más imperativo en las cuestiones
regionales.
Ahora bien, ¿hasta qué punto pueden fiarse
de un país como China? ¿Qué pueden hacer
para no sucumbir ante el gigante?
Pues eso es exactamente lo que explica noticias
como esta:
(El gasto militar de Asia aumentó un 2,8%
en 2021, contrarrestando la caída global
del 1,8% - Nikkei Asia
El crecimiento se desacelera en la región,
pero los gastos son "resistentes" a la contracción
económica.)
Y, claro, ahora tras la guerra de Ucrania
hasta Japón le ha visto las orejas al lobo.
¿Y esto qué quiere decir? Pues que tal y
como está ocurriendo en Europa también aquí
la mayoría de países están preparando los
cheques para incrementar su gasto militar.
Y, ojo, porque aquí tenemos que tener algo
muy en cuenta:
Sí, China se ha convertido en la gran potencia
regional en Asia-Pacífico, pero su peso no
es tan apabullante como podríamos pensar
a simple vista.
Por ejemplo, la armada china es la más grande
y poderosa de la región pero apenas representa
en torno al 30% del tonelaje naval de la zona.
Es decir, que hay competencia.
Queridos amigos, amigas, en esta ocasión
no vamos a hablaros de los primeros espadas,
de países como Japón, Corea del Sur, Australia,
Taiwán o la propia China. No.
No. En este vídeo queremos centrarnos en
dos nuevas potencias militares emergentes
de Asía-Pacífico. Dos que aún pueden estar
muy lejos de la primera división pero cuya
situación en unos pocos años podría cambiar
radicalmente.
¿Cuáles son, exactamente, estos países
llamados a convertirse en próximas potencias
militares de la región? ¿Qué influencia
pueden llegar a tener? ¿Serán acaso estos
países los contrapesos que determinen el
futuro equilibrio de poder entre China y Occidente?
Vamos con ello.
Fijaos un momento en este mapa.Lo que véis
en él es el Mar de la China Meridional con
las principales reclamaciones territoriales
de los países que lo bañan.
Como podéis ver, es todo un enorme rompecabezas.
La disputa de estas aguas es tan loco que
hasta cuatro países llegan a reclamar al
mismo tiempo exactamente el mismo trozo del
pastel.
Y, el problema es que China cada vez parece
menos dispuesta a lidiar con todo este embrollo.
Al fin y al cabo, si es el país más grande
y más fuerte de la zona, ¿Por qué no imponer
su voluntad? ¿Por qué no hacerse con todo
el territorio que considera suyo y con el
control de todos los recursos naturales que
puedan albergar estas aguas?
Pues, ¿Sabéis qué? Eso es exactamente lo
que parece pensar Xi Jinping. Y precisamente
por eso el gobierno chino está elevando cada
vez más el tono y sus exigencias sobre estas
reclamaciones territoriales.
Claro que sus vecinos no se están quedando
de brazos cruzados…. Y se han dicho a si
mismos: cuidado.
(La República Popular China quiere llevar
la voz cantante, el problema es que sus vecinos
no están dispuestos a tragar con su criterio.
Porque una cosa es que China sea el país
más fuerte y otra que se convierta en una
potencia hegemónica.
Así que si entre el 2003 y el 2018 China
incrementó su presupuesto militar un 621%,
Vietnam lo hizo un 687%. Y otros países como
Indonesia o Tailandia, que lo incrementaron
en un 255% y un 264% respectivamente, ahora
quieren pisar aún más el acelerador.)
Digamos, que ante la escalada militar China,
cada vez más países de la zona han llegado
a una conclusión: Si no nos preparamos podemos
acabar fatal.
Una idea que ahora la invasión rusa de Ucrania
ha demostrado que no es una exageración ni
un temor infundado.
(China ha militarizado completamente tres
islas en el mar de la China Meridional: almirante
estadounidense - The Guardian)
(Vietnam fortalece su ejército para enfrentar
a China- Reuters)
(Estados Unidos refuerza los vínculos militares
en el Sudeste Asiático para contrarrestar
a China - VOA)
¿Os imaginabais que, por ejemplo, Vietnam
la nueva estrella emergente estaba incrementando
su presupuesto militar incluso más rápido
que China? ¿Verdad que todo esto merece un
vídeo de VisualPolitik?
Pues… Atentos.
[Pero un momento, porque tengo una noticia
que daros. Seguramente la mayoría ya estéis
al tanto, pero por si acaso… Quiero contaros
que la familia de VisualPolitik ha crecido:
hemos lanzado VisualEconomik, un nuevo canal
centrado en una de nuestras grandes pasiones:
la economía.
Un canal dónde indagaremos en las claves
que están detrás de los principales movimientos
económicos.
Por ejemplo, en el primer vídeo cuyo enlace
os dejo en la descripción podréis descubrir
la propuesta que hizo George Soros para transformar
Europa: la emisión de deuda perpetua.
De verdad no os lo perdáis porque estoy seguro
de que os encantará. Por cierto, un millón
de gracias a las más de 35.000 personas que
os suscribisteis incluso antes de lanzar el
primer vídeo. Eso sí que es confianza. Muchas,
muchísimas gracias.]
Dicho esto continuemos.
1 ((LA HISTORIA QUE…¿ NO SE REPETIRÁ?)
Vietnam sabe como nadie lo que supone enfrentarse
a una potencia extranjera: durante todo el
siglo XX se enfrentó con Francia, Estados
Unidos - que os voy a contar - y también
con la propia China.
Así que si algo tienen claro los vietnamitas
es que tienen que estar preparados ante cualquier
eventualidad.
(Vietnam incluyó el refuerzo militar como
uno de los ejes fundamentales de su famosa
política Doi Moi puesta en marcha en 1986
para reformar su sistema económico y adoptar
paulatinamente un capitalismo de estado similar
al chino.
Incluyó entre los objetivos la reforma militar
porque hasta ese momento sus fuerzas armadas
eran más parecidas a una serie de grupos
militares fragmentados mal equipados y mal
entrenados con poca correlación entre sí.
Sin embargo la caída de la Unión Soviética
supuso un importante freno para este cambio.
Vietnam era un país muy pobre y el colapso
soviético no hizo sino empeorar las cosas.
Así que la modernización militar tuvo que
esperar.)
Sin embargo, con la llegada del nuevo siglo
y su apertura al mundo, la economía vietnamita
empezó a experimentar una enorme revolución,
hasta el punto de convertirse en una de las
economías de mayor crecimiento de todo el
mundo.
Lo que hizo que ya en 2006, ante el 10º Congreso
Nacional del Partido Comunista de Vietnam
se fijará el objetivo de convertirse en toda
una potencia naval, tanto a nivel económico
como militar.
(Vietnam ha comenzado a equiparse con armamento
relativamente moderno, principalmente de Rusia.
Aunque entre sus inventarios encontramos también
fragatas antisubmarinos de Corea del Sur,
helicópteros franceses o drones israelíes.
Y también, y cada vez más, equipos estadounidenses.
Porque a pesar de su historia las relaciones
entre Estados Unidos y Vietnam se han ido
estrechando en los últimos años.)
Si, Vietnam es mucho más pobre que China
y su presupuesto militar aún es una fracción
del que tiene su vecino del norte, pero si
algo ha demostrado Ucrania es que no hace
falta ser el más fuerte si se tienen ciertas
capacidades y sobre todo se consiguen buenos
amigos.
(Japón y Vietnam firman un acuerdo de transferencia
de defensa en medio de la preocupación por
China)
(La vicepresidenta estadounidense Kamala Harris
realiza una visita histórica a Vietnam)
La guerra de Vietnam ya demostró la trampa
que puede representar este país para una
potencia extranjera. Así que la estrategia
de Hanoi pasa por incrementar todo lo posible
el coste que para China tendría intentar
hacerse con los islotes vietnamitas en el
Mar de la China Meridional.
Esto explica por ejemplo su empeño en hacer
de la flota submarina, actualmente con 6 unidades
en servicio, uno de los eleme ntos estratégicos
de su defensa. Y es lo que explica también
que haya dedicado muchos recursos a reforzar
las defensas del archipiélago Spratly, donde,con
lanzacohetes y sistemas de ataque con alcance
suficiente para atacar islotes controlados
por los chinos y neutralizar sus aeródromos
y sistemas de radar.
Y es que no solo se trata de una cuestión
política o territorial sino también y quizás
sobre todo económica.
Y es que veréis, Vietnam está experimentando
un enorme despegue económico, y cada vez
son más las empresas que lo ven como una
posible alternativa a China o al menos como
una forma de reducir su exposición al gigante
asiático.
Así que no resulta extraño encontrarnos
con noticias como estas:
(Samsung invierte 920 millones de dólares
en la expansión de una fábrica en Vietnam
- Reuters)
(El proveedor de Apple Foxconn construirá
una fábrica en Vietnam de 270 millones de
dólares en plenas tensiones EE.UU.-China
- Forbes)
(LG Display aumenta su inversión en una fábrica
de Vietnam en 1.400 millones de dólares - Reuters)(El
grupo LEGO anuncia planes para construir una
nueva fábrica en Vietnam para apoyar el crecimiento
a largo plazo - Lego)
Precisamente por este motivo controlar y garantizar
la seguridad y la integridad de las aguas
por las que Vietnam exporta todos esos bienes
puede resultar clave para seguir atrayendo
IED.
Pero amigos, amigas, Vietnam no es ni mucho
menos el único país que está comenzando
a moverse.
2 (ARMAS VERSUS MANTEQUILLA)
Si hay un país en el Sudeste Asiático que
aspira a convertirse en un actor relevante
en la región ese no es otro que Indonesia.
¿Los motivos? Los mismos que ya hemos visto
en el caso de Vietnam: la amenaza de China
y la necesidad de garantizar el control de
las aguas por las que transitan sus crecientes
exportaciones al resto del mundo.
El caso es que en Jakarta parecen haberse
cansado de las constantes incursiones militares
chinas en sus aguas. Lo que explica que hayan
querido dar un golpe en la mesa. Al menos
un golpe mediático.
(El derroche aéreo y naval de Indonesia de
125.000 millones de dólares puede significar
“50 buques de guerra” en el mar en los
próximos 2 años - Breaking Defense
En medio de las incursiones de China en la
Zona Económica Exclusiva de Indonesia, el
ministro de Defensa, Prabowo Subianto, está
buscando una gran inversión en equipo militar.)
La noticia tiene truco porque lo que se plantea
es una cifra de inversión a largo plazo.
Pero este tipo de anuncios son una forma de
decir: eh! Estamos aquí y durante los próximos
años nos vamos a tomar mucho más en serio
la cuestión militar de lo que lo hemos hecho
hasta ahora.
Y es que, hasta ahora la cuestión militar
como en la mayoría de los países de la zona
había sido algo secundario. Y de hecho el
Hardware militar de indonesia no solo es viejo,
muy viejo, sino que además buena parte de
él se encuentra en un estado calamitoso.
(Por ejemplo, en julio de 2020 se les hundió
un buque de desembarco de los años 70 comprado
a Alemania del Este. En 2021 perdieron un
submarino de 40 años en unas prácticas de
torpedos, resultando en la muerte de 53 marineros.
Y luego los accidentes con aviones de entrenamiento
y ataque ligero están a la orden del día)
Pero ahora la idea es que todo esto cambie.
Entre los materiales que podrían llegar en
los próximos años encontramos equipos como
el Rafale francés, nuevas versiones del F-15
norteamericano o el nuevo caza surcoreano
KF-21 en cuyo programa de desarrollo participa
la propia Indonesia.
Pero sobre todo la estrategia militar de este
país tiene como prioridad desarrollar lo
que se conoce como una armada de aguas verdes,
un término que se refiere a las fuerzas navales
especializadas en la defensa costera. Lo que
por un lado le permitiría controlar el territorio
nacional - no olvidéis que hablamos de un
país que tiene más de 17.000 islas - y por
otro dificultar cualquier ambición que China
pudiera tener sobre ellas. La idea es un poco
la que hemos visto en Ucrania: puedes ser
mucho, muchísimo más fuerte pero atrévete
a meterte en un avispero como este.
(Es lo que se conoce como disuasión psicológica
operativa. Una estrategia que pasa por crear
una defensa marítima que haga que cualquier
incursión enemiga tenga un coste lo suficientemente
elevado como para que el posible enemigo descarte
por completo sus planes. Que la relación
coste/beneficio no le salga a cuenta.)
Pero para entender realmente que está detrás
de este objetivo podemos echar un vistazo.
por ejemplo, a las Islas Natuna, 272 islas
bajo soberanía indonesia que, sin embargo,
están dentro de la línea de los nuevos puntos
que reclama China.
Unas islas que, además, vienen con regalo:
se estima que en su subsuelo hay más de 5
billones de metros cúbicos de gas. Lo que
podría convertirlas en uno de los mayores
yacimientos del mundo. E insisto son reclamadas
como propias por China.
Seguro que ahora entendéis mejor el empeño
indonesio por desarrollar rápidamente esa
armada de aguas verdes.
La idea es equipar con 274 barcos, 10 escuadrones
de combate aéreo y 12 nuevos submarinos diésel
entre otro equipamiento.
(Indonesia busca triplicar la flota de submarinos
tras incursiones chinas - Nikkei Asia)
Claro que también hay un problema: muchos
expertos apuntan a que los misiles guiados
de precisión chinos, junto a otros avances
tecnológicos como los propios drones le permitirían
a Pekín atacar y “limpiar” la zona antes
siquiera de penetrar en la Zona Económica
Exclusiva de Indonesia. Es lo que se conoce
como “Guerra desde Casa”
Sea como sea el caso es que Vietnam e Indonesia
son dos ejemplos de economías emergentes
que ahora se están empezando a tomar en serio
la cuestión. Y ojo que entre los dos países
en poco tiempo sumarán más de 400 millones
de habitantes y un creciente desarrollo económico.
Es decir, que no hablamos de un potencial
precisamente. Ahora bien, fijaos un momento
en este otro mapa.
¿Recordáis lo que decíamos antes del tonelaje
de las fuerzas navales de la región? China
se está convirtiendo en una superpotencia,
pero es una potencia rodeada que difícilmente
podrá lograr la hegemonía.
Fijaos en el mapa. Fijaos en Corea del Sur,
Japón, Filipinas, Taiwán, Vietnam e Indonesia.
EJuntos vendrían a formar una especie de
barrera de seguridad capaz de limitar mucho
las ambiciones de China y que obligarían
a este país a prestar atención a demasiados
frentes distintos.
Por eso la mejora de las capacidades de Vietnam,
Indonesia y Filipinas puede resultar geo-políticamente
tan importante. Sobre todo cuando estos países
están estrechando lazos con Estados Unidos,
Corea del Sur o Japón según los casos.
El partido no está ni mucho menos cerrado.
La guerra de Ucrania ha espoleado el deseo
de todos estos países de mejorar sus capacidades
para evitar convertirse en una futura Ucrania.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti: ¿Cuáles
crees que serán las futuras potencias militares
del mundo? ¿Hasta dónde llegará el poder
de China? ¿Logrará convertirse en una potencia
hegemónica en Asia-Pacífico?¿Hasta dónde
llegará esta carrera militar?
Dejanos tus impresiones por aquí abajo en
los comentarios. Por cierto, no olvides echarle
un vistazo a VisualEconomik. Ya nos dirás
que te parece.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.